seit wochen corona ausnahmesituationen
menschen sind verunsichert firmen haben
keine einnahmen die regierung muss
einspringen wenn der stadt so viel geld
mobilisiert dann ist es absolut legitim
ein paar kriterien aufzustellen
milliardenschwere dax konzerne fordern
staatliche unterstützung wie die
lufthansa deutschlands größte airline
bürgerinitiativen protestieren gegen die
rettung der vorwurf die lufthansa
verschiebe gleichzeitig gewinne in
steueroasen
das ist ja dann so als wenn man den
notarzt bei der rettung in die tasche
greift ich frage mich wenn wir alle wenn
die allgemeinheit für große unternehmen
zahlen soll müsste der staat dann nicht
auch mehr bedingungen stellen wir sind
in einer veränderten welt wir brauchen
gemeinschaft liste solidarität in der
krise zeigt er sich spendabel enorme
summen fließen alle branchen
autovermieter sixt bekommt einen
staatskredit von bis zu 1,5 milliarden
euro
elektronikhändlers economy mutterkonzern
von media markt und saturn kann auf rund
1,7 milliarden zurückgreifen
tourismuskonzern tui bekommt
staatshilfen von über 1,8 milliarden
sportartikel hersteller adidas rund drei
milliarden euro
mit abstand am meisten geht an die
lufthansa
9 milliarden euro in form von aktien der
staat beteiligt sich zu 20 prozent an
der fluggesellschaft
sonst würde deutschlands größte airline
die korona krise wohl nicht überleben
seit märz ist der weltweite reiseverkehr
um 80 prozent eingebrochen
laut ceo carsten spohr verliert die
lufthansa pro stunde über eine million
euro
die teilverstaatlichung gibt der
regierung nun ein mitspracherecht
sie versichert jedoch laut lufthansa die
mit den aktien verbundenen stimmrechte
nur in ausnahmefällen wie dem schutz vor
einer übernahme auszuüben
doch warum eigentlich wäre eine
staatliche beteiligung nicht eine chance
gewesen um zum beispiel auflagen für den
klimaschutz durchzusetzen
die lufthansa hätte genau wie in
frankreich auch die auflage bekommen
sollen die emissionen zu senken wenn man
schon derart hohe mengen an geldern an
finanzhilfen an wirtschaftshilfen
bereitstellt steuergelder dann muss auch
ein unternehmen alles dafür tun dass wir
die pariser klimaziele erfüllt ist auch
eine riesenchance für die unternehmen
selber bei die geschäftsmodelle die sie
haben sind nicht zukunftsfähig
die co2 emissionen zu senken würde in
zeiten der klimakrise allen zugute
kommen
der protest richtet sich außerdem gegen
die steuerpraktiken der unternehmen nach
recherchen der bürgerbewegung finanz
wende hat die lufthansa 92
tochtergesellschaften in sogenannten
schatten finanzzentren wie irland der
schweiz panama oder den cayman islands
auf malta so die aktivisten ist ein
unternehmen registriert dass mit nur
zwei beschäftigten knapp 200 millionen
euro gewinn macht wenn der staat
wirklich auch in einem unternehmen dabei
ist musste dafür sorgen dass die
interessen der steuerzahler also den
bürgern gehören widergespiegelt werden
ein fachunternehmen großunternehmen die
jetzt gelder erhalten oder elfen
erhalten
transparenz schaffen über ihre
unternehmensstruktur wie sind sie
aufgebaut in welchem land sie welche
steuern nur damit können wir wirklich
wissen dass gewinne nicht verschoben
werden um steuern hier
der staat habe die aktien sehr günstig
bekommen verteidigt sich der lufthansa
chef
theoretisch könnte der staat gleich nach
seinem einstieg mit hohem gewinn wieder
aussteigen das erhöht die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass der steuerzahler
eine stolze rendite bekommen wird es ist
absolut wichtig das waren jetzt mit den
wirtschafts- hilft nachhaltigkeit und
klimaschutz fördert und die unternehmen
die das wirklich nicht verstanden haben
die werden sehr große probleme bekommen
als die werden mit der zeit vom markt
verschwinden schon jetzt musste die
lufthansa den dax verlassen weil ihr
börsenwert in der krise inzwischen zu
niedrig geworden ist für mich ist hier
eine chance vergeben worden unternehmen
stellen sich nur dann um wenn es sich
für sie lohnt wenn der staat mit
öffentlichen geldern unternehmen rettet
müssten die doch auch zum wohle aller
agieren oder